J'ai affirmé que le micromanagement
consistait à attirer de gens géniaux, merveilleux et inventifs
pour broyer leur âme.
Par conséquent, souhaitons-nous recruter,
au fond de nous-mêmes,
des gens ennuyeux et sans imagination ?
C'est une question rhétorique qu'on pourrait se passer de poser.
« Voulez qu'on vous vole votre bagage à l'aéroport ? »
Sûrement pas, non, mais on ne me l'a jamais demandé.
Vous a-t-on jamais demandé, à vous, manager :
« Voulez-vous recruter des gens mornes et sans imagination ? »
Comme on est à TED, on a préparé nos chiffres.
On a posé cette question à des centaines de gens.
Des centaines de managers dans le pays.
Voulez-vous recruter des gens ennuyeux et sans imagination ?
Question intéressante.
Avec des résultats intéressants.
94% ont affirmé que non.
On n'a pas envie de recruter des gens ennuyeux et sans imagination.
6% n'ont pas dû comprendre la question.
(Rires)
Mais, Dieu les bénisse,
ils le veulent peut-être vraiment.
Mais 94% ont dit non, alors, pourquoi continuons-nous de micromanager ?
Je pense que c'est un phénomène vraiment très simple
que nous connaissons tous sans l'avouer, et que nous avons tous éprouvé.
Quand on est recruté par une organisation,
que ce soit un club, un bureau d'avocats,
une association pédagogique, peu importe.
Personne ne commence au sommet.
On démarre en bas de l'échelle.
Pour faire quoi ?
Travailler.
Vous travaillez réellement, n'est-ce pas ?
Si vous travaillez vraiment bien,
comment vous remercie-t-on ?
Encore plus de travail.
Et voilà, vous êtes tous de super micromanagers.
(Rires)
Vous travaillez plus,
et assez rapidement, si vous êtes vraiment bon,
vous travaillez encore un peu plus,
et en fait, vous commencez à gérer le travail des autres.
Et si vous êtes bon à ça, que se passe-t-il ?
Vous gérez les gens qui gèrent les gens qui font le travail.
À ce moment de votre carrière,
vous perdez le contrôle du produit de votre travail.
J'en suis le témoin direct.
J'ai fondé une entreprise appelée Boxed dans mon garage.
C'était le grand moment, je sais ça paraît modeste,
avec le Karcher dans le fond du garage,
mais c'était mon rêve qui se réalisait.
Ma femme était super fière de moi au moment de la création,
c'est ce qu'elle m'a dit, elle était super fière,
elle voulait m'embrasser mais je suis certain qu'elle avait son calepin en main
se demandant si John, de Harvard, était encore célibataire.
C'était comme un stand de limonade qui dérape le premier jour.
Toutefois, les affaires ont bien pris, le secteur mobile croissait
et le marché des biens emballés allait évoluer avec le temps :
on a pris ces énormes colis difficiles à rapporter à la maison,
pas le lot de 2 paquets d'Oréos, mais celui de 24
et pas le lot de 24 rouleaux de papier toilette, celui de 48 ;
et on vous les a envoyés, à la manière d'un entrepôt,
sauf qu'il ne vous les envoie pas.
C'est ce qu'on faisait.
Notre imprimante était très lente.
Et comme notre imprimante était extrêmement lente,
on scribouillait des mots destinés à réjouir le client
au dos de la facture :
« Gardez le sourire, s'il vous plaît »
« Vous êtes fabuleux »
« Quelques Doritos ? »
ou : « Nous aussi, on aime ça. »
Ce genre de petits mots.
Et cela a commencé à rompre la monotonie de notre boulot,
car après tout, on recevait et emballait des colis
à longueur de journée, pendant 9, 10 ou 12 heures,
assis dans le garage.
Une chose curieuse est survenue :
les affaires se développaient.
Sur les derniers 36 mois, exactement,
on a fini par brasser des centaines de millions de dollars,
et les affaires se sont développées vraiment vite.
Dans l'intervalle, mon rôle a changé.
Certes, j'étais toujours le PDG dans son garage,
je recevais, déballais, remballais, la totale.
Puis je suis passé au stade suivant
pour gérer des gens qui déballaient et emballaient
et assez vite, j'ai géré les gens
qui géraient les gens qui recevaient et emballaient.
Aujourd'hui, je gère la direction qui dirige les départements
qui gèrent les gens qui gèrent ceux qui reçoivent et emballent.
À ce stade, j'ai perdu le contrôle.
J'ai pensé que mes mémos amusaient mes clients.
Cela leur a vraiment plu mais je ne peux plus en écrire.
Alors, comment faire ?
Je vais dire à mon personnel comment écrire ces petits mots.
Quel stylo utiliser, quelle couleur, quoi écrire,
quelle police choisir,
de ne pas mordre sur les marges,
d'écrire assez grand, mais pas trop quandmême.
Rapidement, l'objectif de vivifier la motivation de tous
en étouffant la monotonie du centre d'approvisionnement
s'est transformée en micromanagement, et les gens s'en plaignaient aux RH :
« Il faut que le PDG me laisse faire mon boulot !
Je sais comment écrire un petit mot ! »
(Rires)
À ce stade, on s'est dit : « Vous savez quoi ?
On a engagé des gens talentueux et merveilleux,
offrons-leur la mission d'émerveiller le client. »
Donnons-en leur les moyens et allez-y, lâchez-vous sur les petits mots ! »
On a découvert un résultat incroyable.
Certains se donnaient à fond
et ils dessinaient des ornements miniatures pour égayer les documents.
Sur une commande de couches, ils écrivaient des choses drôles :
« Coucou au bébé de notre part ! »
À la commande suivante - des couches plus grandes - ils écrivaient :
« Waouh ! Il grandit vite ! »
Les employés se sont pris au jeu.
C'est hélas à cette époque que ça a déraillé plusieurs fois.
Une personne écrivait simplement : « mb, mb » à chaque message.
On dirait un « merci bien » rapidement écrit par mon ancien boss.
Évitons le « mb » à l'avenir !
De l'autre côté du spectre aussi, c'était parfois trop.
Les employés devenaient trop créatifs.
Comme nous vendions tout par lots,
des lots de couches, des lots de papier toilette,
des lots de Doritos ou de biscuits Oreo
et des lots de produits contraceptifs.
Et donc,
cela devient sensible.
(Rires)
Bref, on livrait des lots de 40 préservatifs.
Nous sommes tous adultes ; des lots de 40 préservatifs.
Et quelqu'un a vraiment commandé quatre lots de 40 préservatifs.
(Rires)
Uniquement ça.
160 préservatifs.
Notre employé pensait savoir comment émerveiller son client.
(Rires)
Cet homme,
voici son petit mot :
[On adore tous les optimistes.]
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
On hésitait entre le promouvoir ou le virer - il est encore avec nous.
Donc, on aime tous les optimistes.
Voici un cas qui a vraiment déraillé
et je reste mitigé sur le sujet.
[CONFLIC]
Oh, il manque le suffixe,
mais comme je savais qu'il y aurait un TED rouge sur la scène,
cela donne « CONFLIC - TED ». [MITIGE]
(Rires)(Applaudissements)
Je vous avais prévenu de mon sens tordu de l'humour.
Le voilà en action.
Donc, j'étais vraiment mitigé.
Nous avions donc commencé à faire des choses
qui n'étaient plus en lien avec notre mission
et des employés n'y arrivaient pas.
Nous ne savions pas si nous devions les laisser faire.
Devons-nous les laisser faire ?
Je ne sais pas.
À l'époque non plus, je ne savais pas
mais je me suis demandé
si l'échec était vraiment une mauvaise chose.
Je ne dis pas qu'il faut célébrer l'échec.
Dans la Silicon Valley, on entend souvent : « Célébrons l'échec. »
Je crains que personne n'ait envie d'emprunter cette voie.
Dans nos réunions du comité d'administration,
personne ne dit : « Chieh, les résultats sont mauvais,
continue comme ça, mon pote ! »
Personne, pas une fois.
Si vous faites partie d'une telle organisation,
contactez-moi, je veux participer aux réunions.
En privé, peu de gens célèbrent l'échec,
mais celui-ci, je crois, est indispensable
aux gens pour le long terme,
aux personnes intelligentes et créatives
qui essaient sincèrement de remplir la mission qu'on leur a confiée.
On peut dès lors considérer l'échec comme une étape
sur le chemin vers le succès.
Si l'inconvénient de ne pas micromanager
est la perception potentielle qu'on pourrait échouer plus souvent
et si cela n'est pas vraiment grave,
quels sont les avantages ?
Nous les avons obtenus, et ils sont assez bons.
On a confié une mission à nos ingénieurs :
« Certains de nos centres logistiques ont coûté des millions de dollars.
Il y a des kilomètres de tapis roulants.
Pouvez-vous faire pareil ?
Pouvez-vous les optimiser sans dépenser des millions ? »
Ils ont relevé le pari.
Ils ont vraiment fait ça - pas de Photoshop ici -
il utilise vraiment une disqueuse.
Ils ont fabriqué un véhicule autonome.
On ne leur a imposé aucun plan, aucun format.
En 90 jours, ils ont sorti le premier prototype :
équipé de batteries Tesla, de vision stéréoscopique et de lidars.
C'est aussi efficace que les tapis roulants
sans même investir dans des tapis roulants.
Et il n'y a pas que les ingénieurs.
Le département marketing,
on leur a demandé de semer la bonne parole.
Il y a une dame formidable dans ce département, Nitasha.
Un matin, elle m'a abordé :
« Chieh, on fait quoi pour la taxe rose ? »
J'ai pris un café, nous nous sommes assis.
« Nitasha, qu'est-ce que la taxe rose ? »
Elle m'a expliqué, c'est super intéressant.
Dans 32 États des États-Unis,
on impose une taxe de luxe sur les produits pour femmes,
comme les produits de soin -
les tampons et les serviettes sont considérés luxueux.
Je n'oserais jamais,
si ma femme me demande des serviettes hygiéniques,
répondre : « Ma chérie, avec cette guerre commerciale,
c'est la crise économique,
pas de produits de luxe ce mois-ci, mais, promis, le mois prochain,
je vais envisager ça. »
La voie rapide pour le célibat.
(Rires)
Ce qui est super intéressant,
et on ne le leur a pas demandé,
mais en collaborant avec les finances, ils remboursent la taxe
que nous devons imposer au client de manière injuste.
Vous vous demandez peut-être :
« Quel est le vrai avantage de ne pas micromanager ? »
Le voici :
Je n'ai conçu aucun de ces projets.
Je n'ai pas conçu le robot
ni la campagne « repensons la taxe rose ».
Rien de ça ne vient de moi.
Toutefois, c'est moi qui suis sur la scène de TED pour recueillir votre admiration.
(Rires)
« Il n'en fout pas une et récolte tous les fruits.
C'est un vrai PDG, ce mec. Il a tout compris. »
(Rires)
La réalité est celle-ci :
je ne suis pas un vrai PDG à 100 %.
Mais j'ai appris la leçon fondamentale la plus difficile
que j'aie jamais apprise
et c'est celle-ci :
il y a une seule solution au micromanagement :
la confiance.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)